Don't you dare, buddy, don't don't don't don't don't
AGH AGH HE'S DOING IT! HE'S DOING THE THING!
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to subnautica now. We've got a bit of a crisis running out of power
We've got almost nothing left
We got to find a new location for our upgraded base
Which is gonna have a ton of power systems, a lot of cool stuff, great features
Good looks totally handsome this and an extra bathroom to boot. Oh, man my hands look awful
(cute laugh)
So I need to find a pristine location for my new base
And I'm thinking I know that I'm gonna need some rather rare materials mixed with a grab bag of pretty common stuff
I'm gonna put my base kind of like
RIIIGHT On the precipice of this that way, I'm close to the main island with the big ol gun
I'm close to the Aurora. Just in case I need to be near the Aurora, and I probably should have gotten Mr. Fister
Damn it, I probably should have gotten Mr. Fister how much power I got probably not enough
Ooh hey, OK
(strange markimoo noises)
Alright
What? Hey, wha, hey! Whoa, hey. Wait a minute!
man something
Something something don't seem right here hmm
Wow
Up and erect at the moment, okay!
To just dive back down here. Okay. Let me see if I can see oh well. There's your problem. Ah
I'm an idiot. That's your problem
(making fun of the voice in Mark's head) Theek fuid intake . I just garb down some of these bad boys got mobile food wherever I go inventory full
Cover up my fuck ugly hands as he munch munch munch munch and to piss to wash it down
Alright, we're good. I feel good who accepted all that piss, but that's okay alright
So we got to get going we got what I got to do is I have all the materials necessary to build another seamoth.
And then I'm gonna call it a seamoth until I actually get a name for it
And I need to look at you guys the comments and then
I'm gonna try to get the start of a new base, and this base is going to be big
It's going to be awesome, and it's gonna be epic those three categories
Remember those those are very important big,
Something and epic hey Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise and Marshall are you doing?
Jeffrey Billy Samwise Marshall, I don't remember if that was the name you you know what I'm an abusive. I'm a bad
I'm a bad father
I'll just say that I'm a bad father, but that's okay because you guys oh you guys are gonna build me a brand new I
I could build that but I don't have the cure yet, so give me a second I gotta go get that personal propulsion
I got an achievement even though I've done. That's already
Put my hands up. I love watching you work. I just can't do it. Oh there she blows. Oh, man!
Had a bunch of upgrades in the other one, too
I'm sad. I'm sad these are rotten. Why are they there?
Hello
Hi Karen you're not the same, it's not the same, it's just not the same
It's just not okay, so enough being a little bitch. I've got this. I'm gonna dock it in my big boy here
Get right in there now
We got to come up with a solution for the power
If we can get a solution for the power gone that means we got to get a bigger base going so what I'm gonna do
Is I'm gonna steal some materials from my old base?
I don't know how much is left there, but at least I can salvage the solar panels off the top of it
You know the best way to progress in life is to haphazardly
Rip up everything in your past and use it its fullest advantage don't care about anything or nothing don't care about what who it hurts
Nothing like that. Just get it done. Give me Oh
You needed copper that's weird probably not that weird, but okay
And these things needed more materials than they used to this is bullshit
Oxygen production of light I am sorry. I'm very sorry about that
I need lead I know I need that I haven't seen LED in a bit lead
Yes, please Gold yes, please okay run out of space
Maybe maybe I should get rid of the rotten fish, yeah
All right, you know, but just because you ask nicely mmm. Maybe I could turn that into Lube
I should who love turning things into Lube Wow that takes up all my space
What am I gonna get rid of my piss no way you ain't separating me from that that's so important to me for some reason
Don't question me things go weird when you're trapped alone. All right. It's all good
It's all good in this neighborhood because that's all the stuff that we had all right. I'm Audi, baby
I love the animations all right, so we're gonna take this we're gonna go to a new space. We're gonna build it up
It's gonna be great. I'm gonna have fun. You're gonna. Have fun. We're all gonna. Have fun. We're gonna have power
More importantly in there anything we're gonna have power. I don't want to be too close that I would anger the
Reaper leviathans, but I want to be close between two different biomes. I kind of wanted whoa whoa
Is that geothermal is that just a?
frisky sand douche
What is that what's going on of the whoo
No now it's just a frisky sand douche all right, okay?
I like the sounds
Hi
Welcome to the party
You know why you sexy shit need to move out of my place because I call this I call dibs on all this
You guys are gonna learn what it's like when I call dibs
Hmm, I'm gonna go with Lube. Give me the good stuff
They are really rowdy out there, and I don't know why it's not even stalker territory
They're usually in the grassy areas, but new what are you gonna do alright? There's enough to get started at least alright?
Let's build me off boys or no one's here, right?
Hey
Whoa buddy, buddy, buddy, buddy, boo
like you
All right, I want to kind of overlooking the precipice into the abyss so I always know that I'm gonna die they are
Everybody all right you stop by some coral. That sounds good this seems a good place
Jenny was lay the foundation down. Um well this foundations being all stupid, but you know it is what it is, okay?
Let's try right there
Lad lead and he's led since when do they need land God they've changed everything I
Don't know what you need
What does it mean anymore do this is everything different? What does it need lad lad?
alright
Hey, hey section okay alright, that's good alright, I'm real happy about that I
Don't like this at all. Okay well
This is a really shitty foundation location not exactly what I was hoping for but you know I'll take it
So don't have a lot of opportunity to complain about stuff, so I got to do what I got to do
I want to actually build a competent room a good base our good base. I'll go base so a good base
Stalker you're gonna be my friend right be my friend
How do I get more lad I don't even know where to get lad
I don't even know what lead looks like what is lad you led
led
Let them know they're now not led and not led
Lad god, I wish I had mr.. Pfister. Oh hey buddy. How you doing oh?
Sorry didn't mean to interrupt a mating ritual
This is a pretty good location because they got red sand right there
I think I've got oh that is some kind of mushroom forest. That'll be good
I've got a lot of limestone outcroppings
Led led yes land, okay good
Hey, hey you
Hey
Not necessary how much space I got not enough leave one more lead
I need another lad that looks like a lead
No, god damn it. It's incredibly disappointed. Let's just dump. I don't need this many fuck
What do I think gonna happen?
gonna blow up oh
Whatever oh oh hi stalky are you doing?
Probably
Fill up my tanks
Jaysus one more lead place one more one more lead goddamn EU sacks of shit or just tryin to kill me or something?
It's almost as if you don't want me building here
It's open and I can't imagine why I'm a friendly guy in a friendly neighborhood anybody that meets me knows that I'm a cool
Happening dude. That's not what I needed but uh
Alright, I'm not gonna say anything sassy about anything because I gotta keep moving. Give me some goddamn
You don't have let do you
Let all right i'ma build another fiducia, and I got it all right time for a fun douching all right
Let's build it actually in line with everything
Okay, I got that build your legs there. We go that's nice. That's real nice. Okay. Let's build another multi-purpose room
feeling frisky
Its builded it's gonna be the entrance of this. I need another multi-purpose room the moon pool is gonna be overhanging quite a bit
That's good. It's starting to look good
It's starting to look real good. Oh yeah, that's nice there. That's nice there. Oh, that's yeah
That's real nice. Okay what I gotta. Do is I gotta find. Oh my god
Okay, let's see if I can make I need courts, okay. I need to go get courts. That's number one private. Hey, buddy just
Decided to give you a little kiss smooch for the road
Maybe the one problem with this areas no courts. Okay cool
We're good. All right
So I'm just gonna be gathering for a while everybody hold on it's gonna be a compilation to me going ooh
Ah, and then screamingly old bitch when I get killed. Oh. Yeah. Oh, yeah, I really like this location
It's in the middle of a whole bunch of good stuff and death it's also in the middle of Death
Pull up pull up. Let me drink a piss maybe if I grab a corpse. No drink the past. Don't drop it
Drink it all right fine that piss is for the wolves
Maybe I should have built it up there ooh. That would have been a slightly better
Hey, cuz then. I would have been a little higher closer to the you know what I'm gonna do it
It's not too late to change it's never too late to change every day is a new opportunity
Yadda yadda, yadda. I'm just gonna be very risky
And I'm gonna drop everything in my inventory right here so that I don't lose it. I just like this. It's a good outcropping
Okay, that's all I good that's literally all of my valuables now
I'm gonna turn my back for like two seconds you guys don't go nowhere house. I disassemble this bullshit. Now. I got you
Please don't kill me oh
Okay, yeah go for that guy. Yeah, go for that guy that guy's deserves that he called you a little asshole
That's what he called you. I didn't I didn't want him to call you. This is what happened
Are you hoarding all that Salvage you shit you'll shit
I'm gonna tame you up by boxes okay back to my bad old habits. Yeah
Dude one do forget
Okay, all right we're good. We're good. We're not good, but we're getting good
We're gonna get good like the scrub. I am okay here we go foundation
Oh look at them legs on you, and you just got the beefiest legs I ever did see I'm proud of you
Oh, yeah, right on the back corner there then that then the entrance is gonna be right here. Oh, it's gonna be beautiful
Oh, she's gonna be a bit. Oh she's gonna be a real. Yeah, this one. She's gonna be up
Yeah, ah she's gonna be a beaut oh
Yeah, oh. Yeah. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah, oh
Yeah
She's a beaut alright. Give me you give me you me all the good stuff
oh
That's a good hatch
Location you ever just look at a hatch and you're like that's alright setting it in for the long haul you know it, baby?
You know it alright. Let me see if I can get some power in this bad boy
I try to be a nice guy. I really do try to be nice. I'm like hey
Don't eat me and then they eat me
like assholes
Okay, that's enough for now. Hopefully I have enough to be able to make a crafting kit to
Bubba big box Barry over there cuz I don't want to cross that distance anymore ah
I'll add full baby ahead flank it
Alfred I complain about such as noise
Like how that other foundation doesn't have legs, but you know physics don't need to work. Oh
Yeah, it's time for the big bump Bobo you're gonna. Yes. We need you we're gonna need lots of you
You mean piss you talking about piss god
I got some piss you want to put piss back in it all good it all good. Oh, yeah, that's right. That's what it's like
Oh is building a base. It is me it is me. Oh, let's get another one of these bad boys off over here
Let's start the ring-around-the-rosy process. I haven't care of da mang no sense
That's the good stuff now the other reason that I'm building a base over
Here is so that I could I just got some celebration paths. Oh girl drink that
I'm sure they are Karen. I'm sure they are now the other reason that I'm building over
Here is because I'm close to the portal being near that gun means
I'm close to the portal which can get me anywhere in the system now. You know if I was smart
I would do it a little closer, but you know I'm not smart, so I'm not even gonna talk about that
But what I can do is I can get more courts and keep building this base up into something good
At least something that I can fill the moonpool out of how much do I need for a moon pool?
Hey, I just need the lead okay, I just need lead so I just got to find lead that's good all right
Oh, I love resource gathering in the dark. That's my favorite thing you need courts
lots of courts
Hey, buddy. Hey, Don. I'm on going this hole with me ground quartz. Yeah, it's the quartz hole
Oh boy, look at all this quartz what I'm about to drown not with this farting bubble right here
Let me just get some of this brain coral shoot it in my face up - I regret
immediately saying words that I just said I
If I could take it all back
I
Didn't think about it. I really didn't think about it oh
Look you can go up oh, I'm sure this
Can I get some explode Oh out of you
Yes, I got it. Ha ha these networks popper ah
Enough for Mork. It's dark. It's dark. I don't like the dark. Okay. Thank you
This is good, baby. I'm such a baby
My god, I completely forgot
I
completely forgot
Holy shit. I completely forgot. Oh my god
Alrighty then
It's just like my nature in this game to charge headfirst into danger like no matter what I do
Hey buddies, no matter what I do
You are much more intimidating than you used to be I don't know why do you have anything on your surface that I can steal?
Yeah
Anything on your surface that I can steal?
Whoa crazy? Whoa cool break barnacle. Yeah, I'm sure he'll appreciate that oh, no copper
Got quartz quartz Sonya and more barnacles. Yeah, there's a particle
Okay, silver all right. I'll take it
All right, oh hell yeah, and I'm close to one of these I've been best route. I forgot
I
Keep thinking I'm Spartan then I'm not oh wait. I'm not close. I've just gone really far away
oopsie-doopsie
All right, eventually, I'm gonna. I'm gonna farm up a bunch of you guys. I'm up
I'm gonna get a lawn of defense I'm gonna keep everybody away keep everything that could possibly harm me away from me
Hey buddies go poop go poop poop for me
Again another thing. I wish I never said all right. I'm actually good
Yeah, son full of a nice poop explosions Dan another thing that I never thought I'd say out loud
Anyway, this is a really good place because I'm surrounded like I'm in a quadrant of good supplies here
So if I can just keep that and not die then I'm fine all right
What am I gonna do
Okay, so what I need to do is I need to build the fabricator that is the number one priority on all these expeditions and
You go right there
And thankfully, I don't need to be computer chip for you, so that's handy dandy dandy duty whoo
You know what I can do. Oh, you know what I can do yes. Yes, yes storage storage
Yes, wall lockers. Yes. Yes, I can do the wall lockers. Oh hell
Yeah, oh hell. Yeah. Oh hell. Yeah, you know what I'm gonna do next. I'm gonna go find some names
Oh hell to the yeah alright, so I've got some names here
I just saw only have room for two names the first one goes to jester J
Who said I think you should build a giant shrine in memory of bubble butt fill it with a bunch of tributes for your lost
Friend and I completely agree. I think if anything I'm gonna put the Keep Calm
Build a shrine oh
All right, okay
Yeah, let me let me
Here's the shrines gonna be right here. Oh
in commemoration of bubble-butt oh no
It's so sad. How do I use this edit sign big big big big big
In memorium
*sobbing* In memorium
*sobbing continuous* Oh noo. That's so sad
Oh God I'm really sad about this. I should build like a desk or something or a counter at least or a bench
Oh no. That's so sad
How do I like this nice bench oh that I can put some stuff on
*sobbing out loud* OOH IS SO SAD
I can build an un usual doll
Right there
Oooh Nooo poor Bubblebutt
Oh.. Oh
Oh I'm starving! Wait! Hang on! Whoa whoa whoa! I've said NO
Nej ! Hang on
Get in my mouth! Get in my mouth! Get in my mouth! Ahhhh. Get in my mouth!
Why can't I pick you up?-There we go. Get in my mouth-in my mouth! Oh
Okay, that was good. That was delicious. Yum! yum! yum! Give me you
Give me you~Oh Jesus
I was in the middle of moaning! I was moaning the loss
You sack of poop!
You poopy-doop! xD
Oh mah gah! I was in-
I was In the middle of something. It's not my fault that I forgot
*sobbing*
It's the game's fault we're getting it the way
Maybe-
I don't know ho ho ho ho ho ho ho
Oh Jeez-Oh God I am an idiot
I'm an idiot half the comments should be I'm just an idiot all right, okay, and
Aimless films
aimless shrooms
Okay are aimless
films
Aimless booms all right said this episode had a really good plotline it almost seems scripted
and I wish I
Really wish I was smart enough to be able to script half of the shit that I go through in this game
But that's the beauty of subnautica. I have honestly have no idea what to expect
Almost all the time that I'm playing this game
I can have a good rough idea of what I want to accomplish
But the beauty of it like there's so many things that can just throw a wrench in your plans that
Nothing ever ever ever goes according to plan
oh
God and I'm such an idiot than I forget so much so often
Anyway power transmitter, that's really important if I get like a geothermal somewhere I could probably do that
oh
Man, let me make one more copper wires because I I need to I need to make another sign
This is really
Really sad oh geez all right?
Not you not you buddy. All right. Let's see right there. That's good all right bubble butt oh
So sad
Okay, but anyway, I will I will
Carry on without bubble butt I haven't gotten a name for the new ship yet
I feel like either you guys will suggest it, or it'll come to me
And I'll do more more of these lockers in the next episode
I'm gonna try to do a little bit of resource gathering in between this and the next one so
Thank you everybody so much for watching. I'm glad you're with me on another adventure. It's gonna be a lot of fun
So thanks again, and as always I will see you in the next video